it's march 2nd 2022 so it's time for
another monthly update video i'm going
to tell you what i've got going on in
march and anything that you might have
missed in the month of february
i always like to begin with talking
about three big things and big thing
number one is a really big thing people
have been asking me about this for a
long time when are you going to have
some merch for us well i have created a
merch store with spring that is
connected to my youtube channel and so
you can see the stuff on the videos i've
created three designs and one is half
our hegel one is i study with sandler
and one is banjo metaphysics and i'll
have others coming out but that's what
i've got for now uh second big thing is
another big thing as well i'm gonna
start doing a new
live streaming once a month on stoic
philosophy and practice the basics i'm
going to take a key concept from
stoicism or a practice and go into it
and then answer questions and take
comments finally big thing number three
i'm really proud of this and i'm glad
that somebody alerted me to it half hour
hegel has turned eight years old uh it
happened just over the the weekend and
it's pretty cool you know from the very
first video that i put out to i think it
was saturday eight years so those are
the big things now let's talk about what
went on in february
february was a pretty packed month and
it was a short month so we really packed
a lot in there
one of the cool things that happened was
i did my first in-person talk since
covid began hosted at the frank weinberg
library we're now doing the
philosophers the myths of history series
again so that's that's really cool news
right we did something on plutarch you
can see the link to that video in the
video description below this
you know we did our other normal events
an ama session live readings from my
book half hour hegel
metal class with scott taruli wisdom for
life with dan hayes i also was on drive
time from riverwest although that's not
going to be continuing on did a
political theory and practice discussion
and
um
uh
worlds of speculative fiction we
continued on with that with philip
pullman's his dark material so a lot of
online events one face-to-face event
i also took over a colleague's class
one of my colleagues at milwaukee
institute of art and design
is on medical leave so i took over his
writing class and
you know
also started my medieval class at
carthage college
lots and lots of client work i'm doing a
lot of
tutorials some philosophical counseling
some consulting and i did some medium
writing as well and i'm working away on
some book projects
as well which is good to do as i
mentioned a little bit earlier i started
a merch store and
you know i thought i would create some
kind of
quirky idiosyncratic designs we'll see
it's kind of an experiment we'll see if
people want to
wear
or
have on a mug or put on their wall these
these sorts of things if they do that's
cool if they don't nothing lost
i will say that spring takes a good
chunk of the change from it i would make
things
significantly less expensive if i could
but you know that's that's what merch
costs these days i suppose and you know
it's nice to have things available on
demand so and if this takes off uh i'll
add some more designs you know um but
we'll see how it does uh another cool
thing that happened this last month is i
got asked to be in a speaker series at
the university of wurzburg
uh in germany and i won't be going over
there they actually said well if you
insist on it you know we'll find some
way to fly you over and i was like well
i i love being in germany haven't been
there since the
90s but um
no i'll i'll do it by zoom so that
that's always kind of cool
i did have one other cool thing that
happened as well i um
had a book chapter published because the
book was published
my uh book chapter on anselm and his
prayers and divine mercy and justice
um video work i
got three half-hour hegel videos done
this month um all the events videos
which you'll find
linked below
um
you know wisdom for life as well the
radio show i i record those sessions
and i released a number of videos
finishing out the series on leguins
earthsea from my class last semester
with a number of videos on the other
wind which is the sixth and final book
in the earthsea series so that brought
that to a close and then i started uh
putting out videos on augustine's
confessions
and also prudentius's psychomachia right
so those are for my medieval class and
you're going to see a lot more medieval
videos coming up soon in in core
concepts
i had done a poll
about the podcast and people
had said you know that they wanted this
and this and this so i i finished out
the aristotle politics book one
podcast episodes in the saddlers
lectures podcast then switched to duluz
and his uh um article or rather book
chapter bartleby or the formula from
essays critical and clinical and then
since then i've been doing
podcast episodes on anselm's monologue
which is a text i'm going to be teaching
in about a month and a half i think in
the medieval class so that's what went
on in february pretty busy
month and a lot of cool stuff there
we have a lot of events coming up in
march so i'm going to run through all of
these and i want to
let you know from the very start you can
put these on your calendar you can also
find them on the reason io events
calendar you just go to the
reasonio.com site and you'll you'll find
them people sometimes say how can i know
when things are coming up it's pretty
simple you know you go to that events
calendar
and all of them are in central time so
if you're going to an online event make
sure
that you've got the right time zone all
right so what do we got coming up on the
fifth that's this saturday at noon
central time my monthly ask me anything
ama session that is an ama so you can
ask me stuff about philosophy you can
ask me personal questions you can ask me
about heavy metal you can ask me all
sorts of things and people do
following that at
2 pm i will have my monthly philosophy
chat for patreon supporters that's a
perk for people who want to support the
kind of work that i do and you know show
some gratitude with
helping me stay afloat on the 9th at 5
00
p.m
we will have our hegel q and a and
discussion session that's the public one
anybody can attend that that's
underwritten by patreon supporters of
the half hour hegel project but it's
open to anybody
on the 11th at 12 p.m we'll have our
first live reading from my book
reason fulfilled by revelation the 1930s
for
christian philosophy debates in france
and we're going to be getting towards
the end of it we will actually finish up
with all these readings uh this this
month so that'll be on fernan von
steinbergen's the society told me second
day of studies in the notion of
christian philosophy
then right after that the next saturday
uh on the 12th at noon we'll have our
worlds of speculative fiction series and
we are doing octavia butler's parable
novels the parable of the sower the
parable of the talents a very prescient
uh hopefully not completely prescient
but a very prescient set of novels about
social and environmental uh breakdown
within the united states uh just you
know a
a dozen or so years from from now
then uh at
on on the uh
13th that's that sunday we're at noon
we're going to have that new
live streaming
stoic philosophy and practice the basics
and i'm going to be talking about one
really key idea the four virtues so if
you've got any confusions about what
virtue is in stoic as you might have
heard that stoicism says virtue is the
the only good we're going to be talking
about what that means and what the
virtues are and how justice includes
kindness and things along those lines
on the 17th at noon we'll have another
live reading from my book and that will
be maurice blondel's for an integral
philosophy
on the 19th at noon we'll have classic
middle class scott tarrouli and i are
going to be
discussing
metal parodies and parody groups and
whether they count as metal or not so
everything from spinal tap to steel
panther
join us for that it's going to be a
great conversation
on the 24th we'll have at noon another
live reading and we will finish up the
book hopefully with leon noel's
the notion of christian philosophy
then on the 26th at noon we'll have our
political theory and practice live
stream i haven't decided the topic yet
there's a lot of stuff kind of floating
in the air due to the
russia-ukraine conflict so i might be
talking about that or i might be talking
about the original topic i had in mind
that of toxic freedom
and then finally on the 31st we'll have
the mke that's milwaukee stoic
fellowship we're working our way through
diogenes laertes summary of christian
summary of stoic philosophy i got got my
mind on my my book for a second um so if
you want to
learn about stoicism
and what uh the stoics
had to say and you know what their their
views were
that's a great place to go as well as uh
to to you know some of the other things
that i'll be doing
i imagine i'm going to be just as busy
with clients this this month i'm getting
to the point where i probably can't take
on too many new clients because i've got
so many
already booking my time or coming my way
i'm going to be doing some more writing
and mediums still working on book
projects including stoicism today volume
4. if you don't have stoicism today
volume 3 you might want to check that
out
and what else do we we have coming up so
video work um
half hour hegel project you know just
mentioned it turned eight years old i'm
gonna try to get my six videos for the
month done it's pretty rare that i make
that quota but i'm going to try to shoot
for it anyway
i've got some books to review
i've i've been meaning to get to for a
while i want to do some more sadler's
stories and probably some personal
videos and of course there'll be videos
from all these online events as well
that you can check out core concept
videos a lot more on augustine's
confessions i'm going to be shooting
content on boethius's consolation of
philosophy which is the next big text
that we have coming up not sure whether
all that will come out
by the end of the month but we'll we'll
see what we can pack in
finally
podcast stuff so
i'm you know finishing up with anselm's
monologian
at least the portions of it that i'm
using for my medieval class and then i
promise to get on to aj air i've got
some podcast episodes to edit on his
language truth and logic so those of you
interested in verificationism and
analytic philosophy you got a little
treat ahead of you and then i'm going to
be doing a deep dive back into
cicero and doing some stuff
on
his work on the ends also called on
moral ends
having to do with stoicism and
epicureanism
and that will probably take us to the
end of the month so
long busy month ahead of us i hope this
is a great month for all of you and i
hope to see you here in some of these uh
online events and let me throw in a plug
a reminder if you've been asking for
merch now's the time to put your money
where your mouth is and
see if there's anything that you'd like
to buy for yourself or as a gift for
somebody else it's one of those things
i'm do is doing it as an experiment if
it
takes off i'll put more work into it if
it doesn't take off probably not going
to put more work into it but i did what
people asked and now we'll see how it
goes so anyway uh hope you all have a
great month and i'll see you in the
interwebs
you